all right just got on a plane with
hawaii
we're on our way to dallas to pick up
his car
[Music]
all right they're here to take my jetta
away farewell car of my twenties i'm
actually gonna miss this car because
i've actually had this car since the
beginning of my relationship for tiff so
it's
it's definitely got a lot of
sentimentality to it
but
i'm in my 30s time for a family car
so we're here to pick up your brand new
2022 kia tell you ride that you've been
wanting for years yes i have why have we
put off buying it because i'm lazy so
like all these years i keep telling
casey like go ahead and get your car
you've been wanting your car go and get
it and he just was too lazy to look for
it and the longer he waited the more the
prices went up now there's a crazy
markup especially in california so i
thought we flew all the way to texas
to come and get his car for some
significant savings so we're going to be
driving it back this weekend it's going
to be an adventure
it was like a last minute trip to come
out here my brother's here he's actually
driving a brand new kia we're going to
be like the kia pros now i'm getting a
kia he has kia super excited because
i've been wanting a new car since like i
want to say five years ago and it's
changed over the years initially i
wanted to go be rugged so i wanted to
keep wrangler initially i'm gonna get a
jeep wrangler and i'm gonna go out there
and camp and climb rocks with my jeep
that never happened at some other point
i was like you know what it's not the
wrangler it's going to be the forerunner
the forerunner's got more of a sleek
look so it's going to look good in the
city but it can definitely be capable
off-road never really happened and then
after that it was just kind of like oh
maybe we're going to go like luxury
first you know let's go volvo you know
safest car in the world i just kept
coming up with excuses not to buy a car
because like i don't really like
spending my own money i like earning
money but i don't necessarily like
spending i think i have an aversion to
spending my money because i just it just
hurts just throw money away you don't
have that you know i feel you i just
accidentally spent 500 dollars
accidentally well we went to this store
called neighborhoods i thought it was
like like a store that sold stuff but
yeah some pretty expensive stuff yeah i
knew it was gonna be like that it was
gonna be some money i just didn't think
it was gonna be right 500. i get that
feeling even when i check out on amazon
and i'm buying like toilet papers and
i'm like man toilet paper is kind of
expensive
and then the tell your ride came out
about two years ago and it just changed
my mind about any other car i've ever
wanted all i'm really looking for is for
a car not to look like a soccer mom car
and i don't tell you right in theory is
basically for soccer moms but it's a
cool ass soccer ball car more like put
the kids in the back and just drive the
family around if you haven't heard yet
we're pregnant
there's a baby in there so we're
pregnant and we're thinking why not why
not get that family car why not get the
suv i know i think isaac's gonna
appreciate it too because he's gonna
have
like captain shares in the back and all
this stuff like yeah just
feels it's about time
[Music]
oh he finally got his baby
[Music]
[Music]
how does it feel sir this is awesome
the moment you've been waiting for for
years
this car's gonna match tesla the the
color scheme it's very on the outside
and then like a lightning carrier yeah
it's true we're twins
this is so cool we got the family hauler
now
all the times we've ever moved all the
time like we just needed it
[Music]
new family member family member bruno
yeah
you're tiny i know they've been sending
photos and videos of him since they got
him
and
we thought he was a lot bigger he's so
small
cutie
you want a dog
i don't want to train a dog we can get a
puppy the same time our baby comes and
they can grow up together like best pals
no like in the movies
[Music]
[Applause]
i noticed that she separated all the
ingredients from the block
because she remembers that i didn't like
one ingredient which was onions but she
didn't she didn't remember which one and
she was so sweet and separated that is
super thoughtful that's so thoughtful
and then your brother bought sparkling
water because he's like yeah i don't
drink this but i always see it at your
house so i just wanted to have drinks
for you guys i'm like you guys are so
thoughtful i like she makes like so many
different songs
you guys are awesome
for like four people all of us three for
four people oh we're doing it big
tonight
[Music]
presence we don't know that we said
he or she
or they yeah i'm here
like her uncle
and oh my gosh dude it's exciting to
have you out here
oh my gosh
what do you call him an astronaut you're
going to be a great little astronaut in
your spaceship you're just going to be
chilling and it's going to be great and
then one day you're going to come out
here and it's going to be the best
you're going to have so much fabulous
second trip to texas yeah my hand's all
dirty wait so you were currently
pregnant for the
opening but i didn't know oh
i didn't even realize that yeah easy
i was like freshly pregnant like a week
pregnant
maybe
yeah weeks okay oh because i almost took
a pregnancy test before here because i'm
like i have a feeling maybe but i'm just
felt at home yeah like i just
intuition-wise i knew but then i didn't
i didn't want to test too early and then
be disappointed again like last time so
i waited until my period was like two
weeks late or like a week and a half
lately
and then i tested and so that means like
i could have just been here and we could
have found out
bruno
[Music]
all right good morning everybody today
is the day that we're starting our road
trip back to los angeles from dallas
texas very very exciting we stayed at my
parents place last night they're
actually on a trip of their own and they
weren't here so we stayed here by
ourselves for the very first time ever
because they've always hosted us and
it's kind of weird not having them host
us buenos
good morning from the brand new 2022
kia tell your ride
owned by this man right here
very happy man yes i am this is gonna be
the very first time i ever do this drive
this is a insanely long drive i grew up
hating being in the car like i never
grew up doing road trips at all i was
just like get me from point a to point b
and that's it i don't care about the
journey like i just want to get there so
this is definitely going to be a
challenge for me because the most i've
ever been in a car is maybe
one of the road trips we took as a
family but uh
yeah like from here from dallas maybe
like new york arkansas or new orleans
yeah one of those that was probably the
longest i've ever been because besides
that it's six hours to san francisco and
i've done that a few times yeah this is
a two-day road trip yeah this is halfway
across the country like being pregnant
you know like i'm more susceptible to
cramps
oh my brother's calling yes we're right
around the corner casey says for two
minutes
so being pregnant i'm more susceptible
to getting cramps
and just like more stiffness and it's
just like a little bit more
uncomfortable but luckily i'm in my
second trimester it's the best trimester
to be in to do this kind of thing to do
this kind of road trip or to travel at
all first trimester was nothing but
nausea
and tired
like fatigue
and a whole bunch of other stuff and
then this one this trimester
it's just like okay cool i got my energy
back i'm not nauseous anymore i'm able
to like actually have nails the reason
why i talked about cramping though is
because i was leading to talking about
how the fact that i'm actually wearing
compression socks i always wear them on
flights even before i was pregnant
but um these new socks that i got
they're so
tight like i feel like it's cutting off
the circulation in my legs but i don't
know supposedly it's supposed to be a
good thing right so but i'm like the
outfit that i'm wearing i feel like i
look kind of funny because you can see
the compression socks too
i'll show you right now i just i look
like a nurse like this is how nurses end
up dressing you know with the socks all
the way to the knee
and then white shoes i'm ready to uh not
get cramps yay
[Music]
pumpkin
donuts
[Music]
[Music]
all right they're carried away to
my wifey
is baby full
yes we have a combination we have a
human
and food baby combo yeah so kia bro
my brother bought his car like a month
before i came down here to get mine
and uh we were both considering kias at
the same time i was on the verge of not
going with kia because they were just so
overpriced and i was gonna go over the
nissan pathfinder and uh since my
brother got a kia that was kind of like
the last thing for me to be like yeah
you know let's just go get that tire
right
[Music]
hi baby you're saying goodbye
you're saying bye to the baby too okay
it's so weird because like i want to put
a like a face to the baby but like
there's no face i can't do it i can't
even put a gender imagine put together
this like merged together
that's the baby
[Music]
all right we are now in childress texas
stopped to get some lunch my wifey and
the baby was craving some sonics and so
we stopped to get some sonics i haven't
been to science
it's not sonic i keep correcting them
too i'm like you know it's sonic right
not sonics all the other fashion places
are mcdonald's arby's chick-fil-as
yeah obviously anyone else obviously
taco bells oh that's sonic growing up
and uh yeah this is kind of nostalgic
but i haven't been to one in like i
don't know like 20 years now and so i've
only ever had sonic um because there was
one near the hospital that i worked at
the first hospital i worked at i had
always seen the commercials and i had
never ever ever come across one
in the wild and then when i found out in
the wild
when i was working there i was like oh
my gosh there's a sonic here i can
finally try it i still remember that
younger tiff that would be so excited
about sonic because it's like oh my god
a unicorn i've never seen one i've never
eaten that one it is really rare in
california to see it sonic because i
don't think they have the space to build
out the the drive up style lots yeah
this was in the oc too it wasn't even in
l.a and that's where you find parking
lots
it's a typo it's a problem with
corporate they really need to fix that
typo
[Music]
where i'm from everyone calls it a week
i know i think we just call it a hot dog
yeah i was about to say what do you call
it again you just called the the meat in
the middle of a hot dog is called a hot
dog you call a hot dog yes yes so we
call it a weenie and then we taste like
a hot dog i think you're right i think
technically you're right and it is a
weenie and then you put it in the bun
and becomes a hot dog yeah i think where
i'm from i think people are very lazy
and they just refer to it and how do you
know like if you're making hot dogs and
you need the weenies like do you tell
someone like pass me the hot dogs you're
talking about hot dog without the buns
you want to talk about hot dog with the
bun oh yeah that's true maybe we just
don't like saying the word a weenie
[Music]
yeah what do you guys call it tiff said
this is our first meal in my car and
it's sonic's
he still said sonics
cause this car is beautiful as it looks
right now it's gonna be a wreck as soon
as this little boy or girl comes in
they're gonna destroy this car so might
as well that seat in particular yeah
probably that one oh yeah i can't reach
that i'm here i can't read oh if you're
here if i'm here probably that one if
it's just you alone would be that one
yeah cause i'm like i can i can't reach
i can't see this oh my god you know it's
funny it sounds like it's a brand deal
[Music]
we just keep talking about sonic sonic
science sonic lots of us
well i don't want sonic to sponsor us i
want sonic's wonderous doesn't sound
better saying sonics
no okay fine i'm crazy
[Music]
[Music]
yes yeah so amarillo by morning is a
country song that i used to like
listening to a lot the reason why i
became a thing in our relationships
because early on like i would speak a
lot of spanish every other word was in
spanish i had to like accustom myself to
not speaking so much spanish but i
remember one time
i said something i'm like oh that means
and then you go amarello
oh yeah i've actually never heard the
song i've only ever heard you sing it
yeah i was you making fun of me saying
amarillo which is yellow
[Music]
all right we made it to our hotel where
we are in albuquerque
we're in new mexico
oh yeah
[Music]
kind of looks like vegas without all the
lights windows dirty all right let's go
get dinner so we're going to meet up
with chef's family yeah my cousin so i
actually have two cousins that live here
but apparently one cousin didn't tell
his sister that i was coming
so we're only gonna see him i'm really
bummed because i haven't seen my other
cousin since isaac was a baby like we
haven't seen each other since forever
and
this woman doesn't answer her phone so
i'm really sad that
we don't get to see each other but at
least i get to see her brother my other
cousin
who are we with right now we're with my
cousin
what's up pablo
family hello family
she's also pregnant by the way we're
like a month apart
[Music]
we're now in arizona
doing a arizona pit stop bought some
souvenirs got an ice cream for the baby
the baby was craving an ice cream i mean
i wasn't on them
sure yeah
um
sometimes i like chomping it off
true and there's like a little like
point yeah
all right we just paid the entrance fee
to
the national petrified rainforest i
don't know what it's called rainforest
like the petrified national
forest is it a forest they call it a
forest
pretty sure it is yeah right here here
petra rainforest that's so funny that's
beautiful petrified forest national park
there we go we decided to do a little
tourist trip check out the petrified
forest see what it's all about
this is beautiful wow look at that
[Music]
oh that's crazy
yeah that's so cool it looks like wood
actually kind of looks like hard candy
and i kind of want to break a piece off
and eat it such a sucker for tourist
traps like i want to go to the visitor
center and buy a little piece of
petrified wood now and take it home
let's go
[Music]
what's going on with your jacket over
there in front of me now
[Music]
and what's going on down there and
what's going on with your seat belts
oh so i purchased this uh
seatbelt holder thingy for pregnant
ladies so the belt doesn't like squish
it to the baby it's been very helpful
because people are driving wild today
and i've had to like slam on my brakes a
couple times yeah and and if i was if i
didn't have this the belt would be like
digging into the beginning but instead
it's digging into my side
so it's a lot safer
[Music]
oh snaps pulling in for the first time
welcome to your new home tell your ride
[Music]
home sweet home
[Music]
you